le froid et la neige n'ont pas eu raison
de leur mobilisation
une centaine de policiers manifestaient
ce matin et sous les flocons devant les
locaux de la sécurité départementale
la cause de leur ras-le-bol le projet de
réorganisation de la police qui prévoit
la suppression de la brigade
anticriminalité autrement dit la bac d
erin ce projet avant tout c'est la
dissolution d'unité qui interpelle
annuellement plus de 400 individus
sachant qu'un délinquant ne connaît ne
commet pas celle d'elie il en commet
plusieurs donc c'est une conséquence
fâcheuse pour ce pour ce département
et puis aussi il faut prendre en compte
bien évidemment et bien l'intérêt de mes
collègues qui se trouvent aujourd'hui
derrière moi tous ses collègues de de la
bac départementale qui re vrai durant
des années et à qui on va demander de
demain va tout simplement quitter cette
unité est allé travailler vers d'autres
cieux vers d'autres cieux c'est à dire
vers d'autres services dans les
commissariats locaux
la brigade des stupéfiants des yvelines
seraient également concernées en tout
une quarantaine de fonctionnaires un
moyen de grossir les effectifs des
polices de proximité sans créer de
nouveaux boss si les policiers n'ont pas
le droit de grève leur solidarité a
permis une forte mobilisation ce qu'ils
demandent aujourd'hui c'est d'être
entendu
la première se des solutions serait déjà
de deux de nos écoutes et de nous
convoquer et de nous dire exactement où
ils veulent où ils veulent en venir
puisque nous sommes bien évidemment
attaché à
une meilleure et une qualité du service
public mais que ça ne se fasse pas au
détriment de nos collègues
le directeur départemental de la
sécurité publique a reçu une délégation
en fin de matinée le jm mentionné sur
les slogans n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer
devant nos caméras
il attend tout comme ses policiers une
réaction du préfet